non so se ve lo ricordate paper io
questo sito che ti permette di
conquistarci la tua zona
un po come fa la russia l'ultima volta
che ci ho giocato avevo giocato a
versione classica che questa qua e
facevano e una così almeno rientro un
attimo in nell'ottica di gioco senza
morire grazie a dio
ecco ve lo spiego un attimo abbastanza
velocemente bisogna creare il territorio
in questo modo uscendo e se tu tocchi
per qualche motivo un avversario lo
escludo fa esplodere lo scoppi
fortissimo ad esempio il prima e la
finlandia in questo caso non esiste che
la finlandia sia prima rispetto
all'italia che bisogna fare il ciappetta
striscia tutti quanti però faccio questa
partita un attimo di prova per vedere
come riesco a battere la finlandia e poi
proviamo anche perché hanno aggiunto
nelle nuove cose erano quelle che volevo
provare dall'altro sono passato primo
molto bene con la corona tra l'altro
benissimo devo riuscire a intercettare
un paio di nemici series che sono
diventato già gigante il che è molto
buono pat volevi ciao zio quando si è
addormentato sulla tastiera secondo me
cosa ammazzato la sola che bei rivali
che ciò ecco se facessi tutte ste chi
l'ha anche su fornet sarei ninja però
non lo sono ma il finlandese esattamente
dov'è che non lo vedono non solo sta
cagando nessuno perché non c'è prova a
fare questa cosa gigantesca ea chiudere
tutto sto cerchio enorme se non esplodo
sono un fenomeno perfetto 24 per cento
ovviamente se arrivi a 100 per cento hai
vinto e chiuso tutto l'avevo già fatto
una volta vediamo se scafaro di nuovo
volevi zio volevi cosa stava facendo
quello che l'ha vista al massacro che
suo staff che sta facendo sta tentando
di prendersi tutta la mappa un pazzo
raga sto facendo dei disastri assurdi
nel mentre questi si ammazzano tra di
loro però devo prendere almeno il 50 per
cento di spazio perché se non continuano
a sport continuano a sfornare giocatori
sono fortissimi prima partita prince mi
ha visto partire ma mi spiace per lui mi
spiace proprio tanto ma niente 58 per
cento fa vj signori ce la posso fare dai
prima partita era solo per ricordarmi
come si giocava sto vincendo
pensa se provavo e un tutorial
praticamente questo contro gente vera
però certo guardarli guardali uno contro
uno
questo minuscolo tra l'altro non è vero
continua raggiungersi giocatori devo
chiudere il più possibile lo spazio che
continuano a suonare qui
che sfiga zio smettila di morire o
perfetto no
mammamia pensa che culo la finiamo di
spronare qui la finiamo basta
il gioco è bello finché non spadoni più
ciao e stato veramente bello conoscerti
ragazzi no ma cosa continua a scalare
gente la pasta no madonna come mi sono
salvato
raga ho rischiato in una maniera che non
avete idea ho rischiato fortissimo
meno male no ammazzati un milione raga
sono stato bravissimo
giuro ed era una partita di tutorial ci
è più che altro volevo vedere come si
giocarmi cordano più ed è andata così va
be free to one led che uno come me è
rimasto un pezzettino alle ci prova dai
bene non volevo farcene senso non
pensavo di riuscire a farcela subito ok
io ero qua adesso visto ricorda come si
gioca ero qua per testare le altre
modalità in realtà dieci minuti precisi
quasi ha giocato aver ammazzato 12 gioca
fuori dei casinò fortissimo change che
in modo ho visto che hanno aggiunto rob
e quindi fast speed proviamo parco
demonio ma siete scemi
questo con la velocità pura e non è
bellissimo
era questo che volevo fare all'inizio
volevo vedere le cose nuove solo che era
per testare un po come si giocava per
ricordarmi ho vinto quindi ok vediamo se
a velocità aumenta tales comunque essere
forte no
a quanto pare no sono stato battuto da
sara johnson brava sarà tra l'altro
questa cosa è una cosa che mi chiedo io
se io copro tutto qua facciamo così
riguarda copro tutto ok e poi faccio il
giro completo
dite che vincolo
cipro faccio il giro completo di tutto
mentre gli altri si ammazzano non
sarebbe stato troppo bello se riesci a
fare il giro completo senza i dati se ne
accorgono vinci però è impossibile che
non se ne accorgono devono essere ciechi
ci proviamo
altra gente si ammazza spera non disponi
nessuno vicino non ricordarlo
ricordandomi guardare non ricordare
brava manda brava manda nokia che non c
è difficilissimo
penso non possa esistere da questa
possibilità
penso non si possa vincere così perché
c'è la gente deve essere veramente
stupida però se riesci tipo in giro solo
a fa vincere 6 fenomenale questo
gigantesco scala cave cambiamo perché
abbiamo modalità facciamo slot feed
turtles mamma mia che mi cadono le
braccia ragazze mori qua ti incazzi
passi un ora giocare
cambiamo c'è un'altra modalità small map
small map più fast speed
ma prima ha proprio piccola la mappa
piccola parte che larga che la metà
basta l'orribile se riesco a se non
muoio ma penso di morire adesso che è
perfetto
proviamo a fare mappa piccola eppure
veloce quindi fas tema più fast speed
small ma più fas speed o ciao zio è
stato un piacere
vediamo se riesco a fare fuori tipo metà
mappa in una botta sola è volevi frate
volevi volevi nella tua vita volevi
ragazzo al 30 per cento
dobbiamo stare attenti ai nuovi bond
perché gli spunti buttano giù subito ne
va beh vabbè ho appena detto questa
frase l'ho appena detta l'ho appena
detto ho detto che bisogna stare attenti
e louise von perché ti spara in faccia
non puoi fare niente ti spacca non te ne
accorgi nemmeno grazie già bada molto
gentile 12 3
a paceco l'altro verde fortissimo ci può
solo essere un verde vincitore in questa
partita non puoi essere tu
sappilo se non lo sai sanno e infatti è
morto bene vai vai vai così mi piace
questa partita mi piace e non di
conquistarle tutte trachea questa è
dominata di partita non la posso perdere
mio dio nonché essere più grosso mi
conferisca vantaggi ma vorrei essere più
forte dei miei avversari in teoria si
spera sempre se non faccio cagate cipo
questa che sto facendo
e poi mi devi prendere i pezzi mi dà
fastidio come inizia la mangiarti tutto
anche la famiglia
nondimeno subito quello che è piaciuto
che piaciuto west
ti è piaciuto questo la vita fa schifo e
dovete esserne consapevoli ragazzi prova
a fare l'ultima proprio devo essere
carico
magari non questa persona non altro il
primo si chiama metacarpo se non batto
uno che si chiama metacarpo se ne va
dove lo dico ok sono rei sono esplosi
tutti seri ma sir francis e francis è
morto è spuntato un altro i portavoci
del minho mi ha ucciso molto bene no
perché la gente migliori spa una
rinfaccia qual è il problema della gente
mamma mia quanto rischiato con questo se
more to ho vinto in teoria in pratica
zone ciao zoe americana vero potrei
anche avere il mio numero dopo una prima
devo ucciderti
ma è però non è che possa darmi gente
random e rega fatevi una vita per
cortesia francis
c è un gioco per halloween nel senso che
questo gioco ti fa incazzare manco fossi
un vampiro assetato di sangue però
quello è un altro discorso
ho vinto la prima partita sono contento
così
chissenefrega del resto è già un
miracolo che non abbia vinta una rotta
vendere casuali spero che vi sia
piaciuto concludo qui l'episodio di
paper io come sento ragazzi del video
più lasciare un momento non mi piace
anche vari soci alcuni doveva
descrizione senza presidi schiette vi e
non ci vediamo a non possiamo vita da
ragazzi
[Musica]